je joins minister francois pour nous en
parler mélissa bonjour et vous venez
d'assister un moment assez émouvant deux
amis deux amis eux eu deux jeunes filles
qui sont trouvés exactement des
retrouvailles qui se sont produites sous
nos yeux simon parce que vous savez nous
ça fait quelques heures que nous sommes
sur place nous venons d'arriver ici et
simon même plus de 48 heures après la
tragédie bien on sent que les gens sont
toujours sonnés par ce qui s'est passé
dans la nuit de vendredi à samedi comme
vous le savez on se retrouve ici dans le
périmètre de sécurité et je veux juste
vous montrer sinon les gens qui sont
encore là les citoyens de lac mégantic
qui qui regarde l'air bouleversé ans qui
s'est jouée ici au cours des dernières
heures
on leur a parlé vous savez qu on a à peu
près encore une quarantaine de personnes
qui sont portées disparues et des
tranquillement parlant jean-simon
remarque l'espoir commence à faire place
à une certaine résignation parce que les
gens tranquillement à qui on a parlé se
disent écouter tranquillement on n'a
plus espoir de revoir ces personnes là
par contre comme vous le disiez un peu
plus tôt on a assisté sous nos yeux à
des retrouvailles donc deux jeunes
filles qui n'avaient pas de nouvelles
l'une de l'autre depuis vendredi soir
simon depuis le moment de la tragédie
elles se sont retrouvées on leur a parlé
quelques secondes par la suite
voici ce que ça a donné
parce que j'imagine que vous pensiez pas
je sais pas qui a retrouvé l'autre mais
vous pensiez pas que l'une d'entre vous
étaient sauvés s'était pas vu encore
c'est tout vous étiez ou moi j'étais à
l'extérieur de la ville mais elles
étaient environ jeux d'occasion au salon
du bio un petit peu plus beaux sa
politique celle mais on est des filles
qui sont toutes les deux musiques à feu
et puis on aurait peut être le tout les
deux mois fait était comme la veille
comme la veille comme la veille le jeudi
soir on était là alors vous vous étiez
dans un bar en face près du music a fait
c'est maintenant français pas loin du
métro en hauteur on a tout dit sauf si
on était là on nous courions se sauver
comme tout le monde on attendait tous
crié regardez regardez la boule de feu
on savait que nos invités la minceur
telle
le jeune hacker gens ça allait sortir on
l'a les chercher mais ça n'a pas marché
plein
le
vous avez perdu des gens oui oui
d'eramet qui conte était le reçois ma
belle somme des ennemis m'améliorer
merci
les cartons
témoignage c'est un très très très
touchant très très bouleversant des
choses comme ça d'autant plus qu'on sent
chez la jeune femme qui qui a vu le feu
l'eau traitée en dehors de la ville mais
celle qui était là oui voyez voyait les
flammes et imaginait ses copains ses
amis des parents peut-être qu'ils
étaient pris dans ses plans de là et là
il ya le sentiment de culpabilité
souvent qui s'éveille en nous dans ce
cas là pourquoi je suis pas aller les
sauver j'aurais dû aller les sauver
suite et celles qui se demandent aussi
si mon qu'est ce que je fais encore ici
comment c'est que je m'en suis sauvée
pourquoi moi voilà que ça allait pas
bien mais merci beaucoup de ces
témoignages merci mélissa merci si l'on
se trouve peut-être plus tard merci
beaucoup